When I started the season, I couldn't imagine that I would be able to achieve.
I just feel really, really honored to be among these women,...
...and there are so many choreographers out there that are incredible...
...that aren't in this group right now, but I applaud everyone.
When we get on the ice, you say, "Oh wow! That looks great."...
...but behind the scenes, there's so much effort that goes into it,...
...and we have to thank Mathieu Caron and the whole team.
And I just love being a part of this big wonderful family...
...and doing everything I can.
So, thank you very much.
We want to thank you all for this great honor.
We're so happy to have won this award.
What I always try to do is respond to their expectation at 120% level.
That's why when I tell myself, that this point means huge...
...and when I succeed, it's an amazing sense of achievement...
...more than the words can describe.